انا بقى مشاهدينا الكرام معي في الاستوديو
في فقره وقفه مع الحدث وسيم الدالي وسيم
اهلا بك ومساء الخير اهلا حكيم مرحبا وسيم
ما الذي يقصده بوتين من مقارنه غزوه
بالحرب ضد هتلر هو في الواقع هي ليست
المره الاولى التي يستعمل فيها رئيس
الروسي الحقل الدلالي لمفهوم النازيه فقد
سبق وان شبه الحمله العسكريه باوكرانيا
بالحمله على النازيين عموما منذ اعوام
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يقدم نفسه
على انه مدافع شرس على عن انتصار الاتحاد
السوفيتي على المانيا النازيه في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وهو مصدر فخر للروسيين
وهو يريد ايضا في هذه منذ بدايه الغزو على
اوكرانيا ايقاظ هذا هذه المشاعر لدى
المواطنين الروس بان المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين هم نازيون جدد ويتوجب على رو
انت تدافع عن اراضيها من هؤلاء المسؤولين
ولكن
اختيار
الدبابات الالمانيه في هذا الخطاب في اطار
زمني ومكانيا مثل الثاني من فبراير في
مدينه
سابقا هو اختيار ليس اعتباطيا باعتبار
هناك هناك هذا الاختيار هو اشبه بانذار من
قبل الرئيس الروسي الذي يواجهه لالمانيا
ولكل من يريد دعم القوات الاوكرانيه في
الحرب ضد روسيا بل يريد بوتين ان يذكر من
خلال هذه التصريحات في هذا الاطار الزماني
او المكان بما حصل للالمانيين في ذلك
اليوم عندما استسلم الجيش السادس في
الثاني من فبراير عام
للقوات السوفياتيه ذلك الجيش الذي يقوده
فريدريش
الذي استسلم بعد ايام من الحصار والجوع
والبرد وحتى ان القوات السوفياتيه
ذهلت لما استسلم هذا القائد الذي عرف
بتخطيطه
للهجوم الالماني على الاتحاد السوفياتي
وحتى انهم طلبوا منه وثائقه هويته بانه
هذا هو المارشاد الذي استسلم والذي دفع به
هتلر الى الى هذه الخط المواجهه واراد منه
الانتحار بدل الاستسلام بالتالي هناك
اسقاط تاريخي في هذا الخطاب من قبل بوتين
وكانه يريد ان يوجه يذكر الالبانيين بان
الانخراط في هذه العمليه العسكريه وان
ارسال الدبابات المانيه ليوبارد اثنين
فانها المصير هو نفس المصير الذي وجهه
الجيش الالماني النازي عام
1943 في
هل يمكن للاستنتاج بان المانيا باتت طرفا
مباشرا في الحرب الموقف الروسي في هذا
الصدد واضح وضوح الشمس روسيا تعتبر ليس
فقط المانيا وحتى على لسان المتحدث باسم
الكريملين قال ان تحالف وكل المصادر عن
العواصم العالميه والقوى الغربيه عند
الموافقه على تسليم الدبابات تعتبر منخرطه
بشكل تام وهي طرف مباشر في الصراع حتى
انها اليوم الكريم وعلى لسان ايضا قال ان
عندما نلاحظ تسليم هذه الاسلحه من قبل
الغرب الجماعي بين مزدوجين فان روسيا
ستستغل كل ما لديها من امكانيات لمواجهه
هذه هذا العتاد العسكري وهذا انخط في
الحرب ولكن من الناحيه القانونيه هناك جدل
اخر
الاوكرانيه كل الشكر جزيلا لك وسيم ذلك
كنت معنا في فقره وقفه مع الحدث شكرا حكيم
اهلا بك انا سعيد اخر علينا